what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 2 of our tensor flow at JSC Ruiz in
this video we're going to be doing is
showing how you can begin to incorporate
tensor flow Tijs into an otherwise you
know non deep learning application so
this one we're going to try to keep it
as simple as possible especially before
we get into the next example which is
going to be quite a bit more complex so
all we're going to do is we're going to
take input from a user and the idea is
to graph the input from the user but
also to use deep learning to calculate a
best fit line so just do regression kind
of like what we did before only now more
in an application sense rather than
trying to do it all in the console so I
don't know what the most popular
charting application is in JavaScript I
personally use high charts I was trying
to find something a little more
simplistic so I'm gonna go with chart J
s feel free to use whatever your
favorite charting application is you
don't have to go this route it really
shouldn't matter you should be able to
take what we learn here and apply it to
whatever you want so anyways if you hit
get started and then come down to click
get started again you can see the script
tags basically we just need to copy
these into our code and the way that
this is going to work is it uses canvas
so it plots to the canvas I'm also going
to copy that paste that in here because
we're going to need that soon enough
once you have the canvas I'm just going
to copy it from the text base version of
this tutorial put a link in the
description but you can also see here
kind of how this stuff works it just
takes in it's gonna populate your your
canvas here and then what it's going to
do is it's going to populate that with
this code here so this just defines your
chart this modifies your chart in this
case here's a line graph the labels here
are going to be your x-axis in data is
your Y so pretty simple charting so
that's why I picked it but again if you
want to use something else have at it
now what we need first is to allow the
user to actually make inputs so the way
that we're going to do that is with the
input tag
so I say input and in this case we'll
say type equals number and that just
forces the user to enter a number they
can't enter a letter if they try to and
then we're gonna give an ID for X and
then we're gonna do the exact same thing
with the Y's copy/paste and Y and then
I'm going to say X Colts X :
y : and then once the user inputs some
information we want to let them actually
be able to submit it so the next thing
here is just going to be type button ID
will be append because when they hit the
submit button we're gonna append to the
new data in and then value what's the
button basically just say we're gonna
have it say submit so let's go ahead and
save that and we are going to run it as
soon as I figure out what window I have
it in I guess I just opened a new one so
here we go and I'm gonna go ahead and
open the console just in case we do hit
some issues okay one two
great okay cool so we've got our submit
button but right now obviously like
submitting isn't actually doing anything
at all for us so coming up down here the
canvas what we're gonna do first look
let's let me put this into div tags just
so that it doesn't run off the page div
will say style give it a padding of 50
pixels
tab that over close off the div and then
the canvas will be for the chart we're
gonna say the width equals 600 and the
height will equal 300 all right so once
we've made it to this point we actually
have all the like HTML stuff that we we
need
interestingly why why are these down
here
could someone telling you why they would
what are these doing down there why are
they down there why is that happening
cuz the this is below it why are these
down here I have a feeling that we're
gonna find out later what's going on
unless I just didn't save it let's try
again okay
weird all right javascript HTML all
right so now we need the actual
JavaScript to start handling all of this
HTML so script script and the first
thing is we're gonna save our X's is
just an empty array var wise is also
going to be an empty array and then what
we want to do is basically the way that
chart dot J s works at least is the
order that you submit things is how it's
gonna be graphed so it's not gonna
increment it's not gonna like sort the
X's to be in like chronological order so
I'm gonna do that so what we want to do
is just kind of suggest the
chronological order so I'm gonna go
ahead and just set an initial value so
it's gonna be document get elements by I
D we're gonna get X and then what we
want to do is we're going to say dot
value equals 1 so we're just going to
set the value to 1 immediately on page
load so if we save that whoops
why okay we probably need to put this in
quotes let's try again all right so
we've got a 1 great all right make this
bigger too so hopefully everybody can
see
okay so we set that to one immediately
now what we want to do is we want to
handle for when so like after this set
to one they're gonna set Y then they
want to hit the submit button right now
the submit button does nothing so what
do we need to do well we need to handle
for that so we're gonna say docu man
stopped get element by ID
what's the ID well append so when
someone hits that thing with append what
do we want to do well on click of the
append we want to run function parms and
the function itself so what's the
function we want to run well we want to
say the variable X we want to say
basically basically want to grab those
values so I'm gonna say var x equals
document dot get element by ID X dot
value sorry I think I just do dot value
there and then we want to do the exact
same thing to Y so I'll just copy paste
change this to Y this to Y so now we've
got our four X our VAR y and then we're
gonna say X is dot push X X or sorry
wise dot push Y what is happening why
someone tell me when is a semicolon
required in JavaScript I don't actually
know I just kind of throw them in
everything I don't really think it's
actually required here is it like just
when you I really don't know like what
is just for functions maybe I don't know
anyway so we've got our so we're gonna
populate our use begin to append to the
X's and Y's every time let's go ahead
and save that let me run this real quick
on click dot on click do we say ok so
I'm just used to Python so dot on click
that way save run three great
four and then we should yes cool so now
we can just say X is wise and we should
get some values for them okay so
everything is working as intended so far
the other thing is like I said we kind
of want to encourage people to really
probably not modify X's at all we just
want to auto increment the X so the next
thing that we could say is we're just
gonna copy this paste and rather than
setting it to one what we can actually
say is parse int X plus one because
right now for whatever reason even looks
at here there's a string form which is
kind of silly
so we're just converting that so now
every time they hit the submit hopefully
that goes up three yeah okay 32 three
okay cool
all right so now that we have that going
on we're ready to do the chart part and
I think for the chart part I'm just
going to copy and paste that in because
I don't really see any benefit for us
writing that one out so basically all
the way up to here pasted on a tab tab
and then tab all this cool okay so all
we added here is like this this stuff
okay so we define the you know the
charred and then we modify the char it's
a line graph the options here or just to
make sure we begin at zero these are our
X's the data set we plot wise done so
let's go ahead and save that and again
source codes link to it in the
description we're gonna refresh and now
we'll just start to graph some stuff
just to make sure it works that should
be should be animating I'm not really
sure why that doesn't animate but I'm
not gonna worry about that right now
this so this little error here is
happening on hover not really sure why
everything app works says intended it's
a known issue in their github so I'm not
really gonna be worried about it
okay so now that we have that we're
ready to actually train a model and draw
the best fit line so really everything
up to this point it's really been more
of like a JavaScript tutorial so I hope
you guys enjoyed my JavaScript tutorials
so let's add in tensorflow dot J yes now
so as always we got to define our model
now where we define the model it's
really gonna depend on what your goals
and objectives are so you could either
define the model every time right this
is so basically so think of it this way
if you have a model especially on
something that could wind up getting
over fit you'd probably want to define
it every time this gets submitted so the
model isn't just getting like trained
over and over over so like let's say
every time someone clicks this function
you fit for ten a box well if they input
one more new data that's ten more epochs
well now you've trained for twenty eight
box so if you're not careful you might
wind up overfitting so I think what's
gonna make the most sense for now is
that we just define the model up here
before but it just really depends so I'm
gonna define it here and then we kind of
toy with it at the end if I remember so
Const model will be TF dot sequential
then we're gonna say model dot add and
we're gonna add TF dot layers dot leakey
not capital L Leakey our elu I think is
that's the way they're calling it and
then units so it starts immediately at
hidden layers this is kind of awkward in
my opinion because you hit you do have
to specify the output layer but you
don't specify the input layer it's kind
of awkward in my opinion anyways input
shape : one all right so that's your
hidden layer one now let's add two more
layers
bang-bang 128 will do 128 and then
finally this one input shape is 128 but
we're gonna make it output one unit
because we're doing regression also this
should be a dense layer because it's
your output layer
okay now we need to add the model luck
compile model compile and as usual we
need a loss metric we're gonna say mean
squared error and then we need an
optimizer and for now we're gonna go
with Adam again a surprise
okay so we've got the model defined
let's go ahead and save that let's
refresh please no errors please okay
good great all right so now we're ready
to train it and here's what's gonna
happen so so so the model is so this
will be like a really simple model but
it's still the code will get executed
faster than the model will train even
though it'll train really fast it's
gonna get executed quicker so
immediately we do want to train on the
latest data we could add one year that's
totally fine but certainly before we
graph it we need to make positive sure
we didn't make certain that the model
has trained so we're going to use dot
then so the way that we do that is model
dot fit and we're gonna fit TF dot
tensor X's TF dot tensor wise and then
we'll say epochs I'm gonna go with like
25 for now just to keep it quick to run
and then we do this dot then then open
whoops then open parentheses go away
parameters and then the closing
parentheses we're gonna add those like
down here so in theory closing
parentheses semicolon then we run but
these are like your your opening so like
these are these are open parentheses we
close the parentheses parms then what do
we want to run well we're going to run
this little function so
Eero open curly don't close that curly
close that curly there alright now we're
gonna tab all this stuff over okay I
think we're good
I'm sorry for anybody who's like
JavaScript expert out there but um this
this syntax starts to get really
confusing to a little python idiot like
myself so once we've done that after we
fit the model we could calculate a best
fit that said I'm gonna go ahead and
refresh here and just see if we're
hitting any errors and we're not yet so
great that's good news so now let's
calculate a best fit line so we're going
to say best fit equals model dot
predicts TF dot tensor X's and then I
want to show you something curious so
I'm actually going to say TF dents are
X's dot data sync now as I showed you in
the previous tutorial you if you just
say TF that tensor it's kind of generic
it's it's not
it'll take anything you don't have to be
explicit in this case it is a 2d tensor
and the tensor is of the shape X's dot
length by one and if I save this it
might run okay that's that hover thing
scared me refresh let's say two three
where is our bit oh we're not plotting
the best fit line darn it anyway it does
run let's plot the best fit line next so
let me just do comma here and we're
gonna add one more little data set so
copy paste will call this best fit we
define best fit here so copy paste best
fit right up into there so now we need
to change the color so we're gonna say
border color Bor border color and we're
gonna make this like a red FF 0 0
and then is it back background color
background color and this RGB alpha 1 1
1 totally opaque or totally see-through
anyway I always get that screwed oh ok
save that now let me run it so 2 3 okay
so you get a best fit line already so
that's that's working we we we we
expected that to work now the curious
case though is like I showed you before
you actually could if you just say TF
tensor you don't have to give the shape
right right save refresh - oh my
goodness why it doesn't make any sense
to me I'm not really sure why that
happens right it says it again an array
with shape one but it's expecting two
dimensions I don't know I it should be
able to figure that out but it can't I
think that's a bug I might be wrong but
we can just specify the shape so again
it's just X's dot length by one so you
can just throw in the shape and things
work again nice best fit line but oh my
gosh wow really you just really want to
fight me on this one don't you
really dude
how many times do you think it would
take ya just doesn't want to Train
interesting so that could be one example
of like if we redefined that we wouldn't
see this problem anymore but for some
reason it really wants to stick down
there interesting
okay so I just want to say the tutorial
is basically over
but there's there is one more curious
case let me just refresh this and let's
redefine the model every time the the
abundant is clicked so I'll just copy
and paste that down here just so
hopefully we'll get something a little
more reliable than what just happened
now five what hold up why does this keep
happening interesting me maybe it's the
epochs where's our uh let's see it
should be hey we really shouldn't have
that kind of an issue this early on I'm
really trying to prove a different point
right now and this is getting in the way
okay I don't appreciate this not oh my
gosh this is somewhat comical anyway
whatever so so in the live stream some
people were asking hey man how come they
didn't say like that this is a how come
we have so so with a neural network if
you only have one hidden layer a neural
network can only learn linear
relationships so in a single layer
neural network pretty much no matter
what you do unless I'm mistaken in some
way no matter what you do you're gonna
wind up with a straight regression line
if that's what you're after if you add
more than one hidden layer though we can
begin to learn nonlinear relationships
so the question was asked after the
stream was posted why why is the best
fit line a straight line should not it
learn better the issue is we're using
leaky rectified linear which is giving
us a linear activation function so if
instead we switched to dense which i
think is still defaults to a linear
activation function let's just see
well in other news though it does seem a
little more reliable than Ricky Ricky
Ricky like the FIDE linear anyway it
seems a little more at least a little
more legitimate but it's still linear
and not nonlinear so what if though we
add one more one more parameter and that
is for the activation so we're going to
just here activation and we're going to
add sigmoid so any sigmoid activation
will do including sigmoid so we'll save
rerun 2 4 5 let's say 12
I'm a little bothered at the moment
tensorflow dodges is not working with me
today ok so there is a curve there it's
just very very slight we should see a
more dramatic curve than we are it must
be it must be our learning rate okay let
me visit the docks real quick tense flow
dot drew who's banging API reference
what I'm looking for is let's change the
optimizer just take me to optimize her
yet
doofus no that's not what I wanted
that's not what I wanted
no let's see
I found it initially and then I went
away from it anyway optimizers okay okay
yeah let's take we'll take this so copy
that we're going to come over here yeah
above here
so basically above you know so before we
say optimizer Adam instead we're gonna
say Const optimizer equals TF train Adam
and then give it a learning rate of like
1e negative 3 so I'm gonna get rid of
this I'm gonna hopefully knock over not
knock over my coffee and then we'll take
the optimizer here paste optimizers
optimizer great logic refresh now let's
do 2 to 15 3 really 15 are you kidding
me
I think we're doing 150 epochs
that should do it man that should be
pretty darn good we could go with the
this I really think we've got enough hmm
hmm I would really expect it to learn a
little better maybe our learning rate
was too low that's better but that's
still not like a really solid fit I
would expect a better fit meant
I hate to make the learning rate even
bigger we could do more a box I guess
let's just double the epochs for real
the tutorial is definitely over now I'm
just trying to figure out how to get
this to be the answers that I like
let's do 215 3
dude it's just not that's pretty close
okay I'm gonna write home about that one
I'll take that anyway that's pretty good
fitment yeah all right so that is your
pretty basic introduction to tensor flow
jeaious and combining it to a simple web
application in the next tutorial
we're gonna get a quite a bit more
advanced we're gonna probably not be
handwriting our JavaScript anymore but
what I'd like to show you guys is is to
basically run through the following this
is this example of playing pong against
an AI that was trained to play pong and
so this runs with tensorflow das plays
against um pong and this requires quite
a few more things so training in Python
transferring it over to tensorflow Tejay
yes and then also so like loading a
model and all that and then you could
also do transfer learning in tensorflow
Tijs
to further train the model to maybe even
play more like however you play or
something like that so that's the next
two bit of the tutorials I'm going to
show you guys if you have questions
comments concerns whatever feel free
lean below otherwise thanks as always to
the sponsors anybody else who wants to
support you can do it at Python program
Internet slash support otherwise I will
see you next time